now it's time to start burning off the
calories that we all ate up during the
super bowl
yes some studies get this say the
average person eats anywhere between two
and eight thousand calories yesterday
alone we gotta find this average person
hector mejia live this morning at tivoli
village to show us a quick workout to
try and burn off some of that weight
hector good morning yeah hector
hey there good morning yeah and alex you
know i ate a ton of nachos yesterday
with extra cheese and i actually felt it
when i woke up this morning i was really
really
regretting that decision so this morning
we are
learning how to burn off those calories
with a group of moms this is a group
fit for mom and this just looks so much
fun
it is fun and i feel a little bit
embarrassed because
i gave it a try and i just felt like
you know like a beginner which i am but
that's the great thing about it you can
come
as you are that's what we really really
recommend our moms to do come as you are
we provide modifications for absolutely
every single fitness level
so whether you're looking for high
impact low impact we've got something
just for you
and everyone this is jessica jessica's
going to talk to us not only about this
program but you guys have other programs
to help those mothers who
want to get into this absolutely so we
provide a variety of pre and post-natal
fitness programs across the valley in
addition to
socialization activities like events for
play groups with children
we service non-profit organizations with
community service and we have
opportunities for women who are looking
to try us out all month long we have a
free three-day pass
but we also look for opportunities to
support those in the community that can
really use this community
so what's happening right now yeah so
right now they're working on
our body well program so this is a
results-based eight-week program ties in
meal plans
nutritional component in addition to the
fitness so right now they're zeroing in
on burning some calories with a hit
workout
um and making sure they target lower
body and upper body here at the same
time and
how do you design a workout just for
women yeah so what's really great is we
realize that women
need a workout that's welcoming but also
challenging on the days they need that
challenging uh
exercise too challenging for both men
and women too exactly
yeah we actually normally we have family
day workouts where the dads can come out
too
and i love it because they see we don't
just sip lattes we actually get a sweat
on
i'm glad you uh pointed that out you
guys also have some workouts that
involve
the children too yes absolutely stroller
strides provides activities for the kids
the entire time as moms are getting the
workout on so it's a great opportunity
for kids to see the exercise can be fun
with their mom setting an amazing
example in front of them all right
jessica thank you very much for having
us so
john and alex obviously none of us have
to be moms to
start working out so i guess i'll be
waiting for you guys right here if you
guys want to
stop by we are at tivoli village and
i'll be waiting right here
all right hector yeah thank you so much
you know that does not look easy
the invitation got lost in the mail i
think it really isn't
monica i don't know um i just i don't
know what to say about that